Bitcoin versus gold I think the real
question here is how can we move money
through time and space most efficient
and effectively I got paid in Bitcoin
from Hong Kong to Puerto Rico then from
Puerto Rico with that same Bitcoin I
then sent it to a client in London and
so I move money all over the world at
the speed of light and it cost me about
one dollar or something try do that with
gold you can't so as you can see in that
example I moved Bitcoin through space
very easily Bitcoin wins on a time
element because it can be passed down
from generation to generation he says
always going to be only 21 million
Bitcoin one Bitcoin will always equal
one Bitcoin with gold we don't really
know how much gold there truly is it
hasn't got a hard cap there's always
going to be more gold that you can mine
from the ground it can easily be
confiscated in seized as we've seen over
in history gold also has an inflation
rate of 2 per year because the miners
are always producing more and dumping it
and so over the next 100 years the value
of that gold is going to plummet and so
that is why gold can't stand the test of